welcome to this video acaba in the house
game number 13 of this mini mecham
bleeding 93 one of them most frequent
opponents I really don't remember what
the openings we we played before so not
sure this was was discussed and earlier
games or not ok let's see ya there this
is the position that I definitely had on
the board before there is d 6 there's
also this move which are always found
interesting Knight g4 is irritating move
as if you place age three I can play d5
I think leading to two very very
complicated play not sure that it is
good though if we think about it d 5 f 4
hmm i thought that i had this on the
board before maybe i'm wrong 93 or
something huh ok if I don't play that
this didn't make much sense so fr hmm I
form
c5f e seat XD form so i would see how if
you can also just move the light hmm I
am definitely 94 is probably total
nonsense 93 93 e five then c5 something
like that this looks very efficient for
black I mean of course c5 at the moment
there in f6 is not hanging if he goes to
be five I can play and maybe even d4
takes takes Knight F to take it d3 talk
about weird stuff 96's of course also
somehow in the mix but ok let's let's
push this just as this popular book is
saying move first think later I take
here look take so I already have d3d
three and if he takes free route Lee to
maybe how we dissolve that very Reata if
he takes I can just take F to a play
Queen B 6 and win funny now the sister
all totally coincident coincidental
I didn't didn't plan any of that yeah
here also the capture and Queen B 6
comes into mind that's it it's very
strong no GM obtained we should take it
anyway check i really don't i don't have
a square for the and don't really have
square cm
hmm this isn't this isn't even so clear
the whole thing Jack came start with
this check I guess he's also he also has
night to to see for
wow I wonder if there's something like
Bishop h3 working bishop every Bishop
takes 95 with night III coming or just
night my girls look somewhere if it
takes I have rookie to which looks so
very dangerous i'm down on one minute
thirty time I'm just I'm just insane
sometimes yeah the position really here
whatever whatever it is but here 1
minute 13 might beat might be good for
black but with this time okay
how does he protect it now
regev to make a green earth to mate
check that's the problem is also it's
got three pieces for the three-piece
chest Lucas singing but he was totally
uncoordinated white resigns I don't know
yeah what that was stranger the whole
game was strange I was sort of thinking
about the five if not oh well what was
the whole point and it's funny I really
this is the comp line 93 e five but now
the computer wants to take on be 2nite
be too yeah maybe maybe I mean it's
sometimes mckee easily forget that he's
not threatening to take as III Hank so
something like this I can I can go here
computer says equal maybe now I does a
good good centralized position but
awesome this is how it continues now if
i get Queenie 7 Bishop g7 looked yet i'm
a bit behind in development I'm not sure
about this may be why is also fine I
mean better not fine fine in certain
days but Pooh okay well I went here 95
key for okay so computer wants to go
Bishop f2 immediately hmm this is very
logical this is very logical if you look
at this the pawns staying here mean that
I don't have an open diagonal for the
bishop here here why it seems to be very
much better compass on plus 1 point 3
yeah and now night c4 yeah that's very
strong very strong night coming to d6
and this this piece is now really bad
it's a huge difference without the
exchange very nice very nice line by the
comp so the capture is the real problem
or let's say at least the move that
spoils a clear edge for wide and d 396
chank chank stakes okay and so here
computer goes rookie 6 yeah I was
thinking about this as well one point is
to take here maybe but Bishop b6 us now
the main line I don't know I really
don't know Brooksie one with a slight
edge zero point something 0.2 what is
the the main line of the machine now
it's like a true black no idea totally
unclear but here black is better because
he cannot take I guess which you did yet
here this is this is go ahead and sigh
mean you can only try to cover this for
the moment but I even have this move
which I saw this is this is a clearly
clearly wrapping up things now
threatening made here and this hangs huh
I was a little bit lucky here but very
complicated very complicated stuff okay
thanks for watching